hey guys Ryan Wright is here today I'm
checking out this video Hawkeye sings
about his superpowers and Sheeran
thinking out loud the parody I don't
know what the Ed Sheeran thinking out
loud video is I trust me and I mean I
probably should have checked it out
first but I'm not going to one guy on
the Avengers who sometimes gets
overlooked he's still great but it's
hard to compete with those other guys so
here now to shed light on his own
strengths and abilities to the tune of
Ed Sheeran's thinking out loud is
Hawkeye the level when celebrities are
such a good sport
when you're on a team with the whole
consumer and we're all up there on the
movie screen will people believe that
I'm not quite as tough will anyone even
notice me
listen I've got powers too and they're
pretty sweet shrine Apple a promise I
can do so much more than just a trophy
I'm serious guys I've got a collection
of skulls and the Rays happy trombonist
stop
I once got to second base on my tinder
date cat has got its own Instagram tell
you now
I kick ass in Mario Kart this year I
played an extra in heart knockin open a
pickle jar freakin Hawkeye baby I'm
Casper sue has so maybe I still haven't
lost my virginity but when I Oh are we
scored 70 after six beers yes I mean
about Captain America strain and the
hope becomes a sounding man but I got
7th place in my fantasy league
and a once per tile short carve an
Italian out when I go to Japan Li I get
freak walk
i flirt with the cashier she says that I
rock lay on the water resistance sucks
friggin ha I maybe I uh maybe I'm a day
Oh first off brilliant promotion if that
doesn't make you like it's so weird
because it's not showing you any of
hawkeye kickin ass or telling the truth
about his other abilities but it does
make you actually be like I want to see
more of Hawkeye now and everything to
jeremy renner like at first it seemed
like he was trying not to laugh but he
was really committed to that he's a
wonderful actor I don't recall seeing
him any like actual comedy since he made
it big but I would love to see him in
like a comedy where he's really
committed to the humor because he
clearly would be perfect for it and it's
always cool scene like a really dramatic
actor to go into a comedy I didn't hear
the original song that they're parenting
but I do like how there was just like
random rhymes they did so they made
imagery out of the randomness it was
really funny it was a really funny
sketch and I do got to watch more of
Jimmy Fallon man I remember when he
first took over from Conan no one really
liked him that much and then suddenly a
little bit later everyone started loving
him and then he took over the Tonight
Show and there was like no hate everyone
was like he's perfect so I do got a
check out more Fallon but yeah Jerry our
great [ __ ] sward had a great time
watching that anyway guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter I'm trying to get
product placement from health companies
because if I have to pay for my own
health
this is ridiculous
Cameron and crepes first video I watched
was the Assassin's Creed unity video
with Alyssa be crazy I so remember which
one that is I don't make many of these I
love all your videos and jokes and I'm
really hoping for a shout-out username
Mick that's with an M mean Nick mean I
want you to be mean to this dog who is
barking in the second [ __ ] video I'm
doing my neighbors gonna get the [ __ ]
under control
Mick mean if you watch the trailer for
the game hatred I want you to embody
that main character and take out some of
these [ __ ] people
I'm kidding if any of my neighbors
happen to come across this channel it's
a rather large apartment building if
none of you are my neighbors mcmean is
coming after you do what you gotta do
buddy